hello there reject nation we got
ourselves an official trailer for the
latest predator movie
prey
he's coming for you or she's coming i
don't know we are coming babe yes gender
neutral predator
gender my predators
[Music]
why do you want to hunt
because you all think that i can't
huh
okay i saw a sign in the sky
i'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
pissed off that bear
like the edge for like the revenant
[Laughter]
no
oh [ __ ]
you can't i'm trying to protect you
protect me from what
they're speaking english
that's right man
[Music]
they're assimilated
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
holy crap
it does look really sweet
i know how to survive
[Applause]
oh my god
wow
colonial guy kind of colonizer
i can kill it
wow
oh wow wowie
[Applause]
damn
i can't wait to watch this on hulu
that's where this was meant to be seen
on your phone
whoa
the first predator trailer in a while
that really feels like this could be it
this could be a solid return to form
here
since
you know the first one
man justice for predators
it's okay and kind of recaptures some of
what you liked about the first one well
this really captures that uh great level
of suspense and tension and the way dan
trachtenberg director 10 club rafi
elaine another excellent movie by the
way the way he handles perspective in so
many of the shots like i i'm an animal
lover i i gave up meat strictly because
of my love for animals so watching
animals die on screen is something that
i'm really sensitive to
now that being said
i was pretty badass the way that she was
doing at the same time with the barrier
it was like the way they captured that
from that reveal perspective of it being
and steal the motor just having this big
ass bear move
that was a really awe and what a great
way to to set up the threat level of her
not having any real idea what she's
dealing with really sets up the
obstacles this person has to overcome
and also with having to prove herself in
her own tribe with a like a really cool
character arc for her to go through okay
in order for her to i mean i feel like
most of her her people are going to end
up getting killed off by the time she
can win the respect of the trap yeah
so the last guy will die the second he
gives that single nod of respect all
right you're 100
officially
but no this this looks like every bit as
just immediate and visceral and you know
punchy as you would hope and i mean you
know dan trachtenberg what he did with
10 cloverfield lane in such a restricted
space was really cool and so i'm excited
to see the kind of tension he applies to
wide open spaces and the kind of
claustrophobia you can get from being
out in a field or in the woods or
something like that yeah it just looks
lean and mean and really tangible and i
feel like being back in this time period
i think they said comanche nation is
what they were taking
inspiration from you know i feel like
that's an appropriate way to go because
you are in a much more tangible realm
it's not machine guns and you know
modern tech and i really just love some
of the imagery we got here like of them
walking through the woods at night with
torches and things like that like this
looks like it could be as intense as
you're wanting it to be but also have
some really gripping uh visuals as well
you know some really striking you know
use of its time and place that way are
we gonna be getting some like english
settlers i thought i saw some yeah some
dudes with guns and muskets and stuff
yeah and i bet they're gonna be made out
to be [ __ ] they're gonna step in and
they'll be like what how do we know what
we're doing
let us take care of this
and then you know
musket goes up three dots bluey you know
pilgrims ain't [ __ ]
i'm curious as to what level of cultural
relevancy this movie will attempt
because i feel like you could go just
lean and mean and have that be enough
but i feel like you could also you know
throw in some commentary to make it a
little more rich but i do fully expect
any colonial characters just to be
murked on the spot i mean i don't think
they need to throw in commentary i think
they just need to throw in authenticity
of the depiction of the commentary will
just be whatever people interpret from
the fact that you've got a female
character and yeah no character
predators standing in for oppressive
forces for the outside taking their
lives and land
but also it's going to be like
historical fiction it seems like they'll
be dealing with too yeah because it has
some moments that feel like a little
cheesy but that's predator yeah
cheese first pregnant movie has some
cheesy ass [ __ ] in there man and this
this
you son of a [ __ ] this this definitely
had a little bit of cheesy moments it
feels like that it'll earn some of the
that cool cheesy action versus what
happened before like this feels like
what they should have called another
like it sucks that i think this one has
been flying under the radar a little bit
because a of the reputation the predator
franchise has developed and b the fact
is called prey
not not even like not even a prey a
predator movie
story yeah yeah
i feel like there are going to be people
confused and i i keep hoping perhaps
that if this is good maybe people will
be like you go check out the new
predator movie what there's a new
predator movie yeah it's called prey but
just check it out like i'm glad they
gave it a different title at the same
time i'm like yeah it's gonna mean an
uphill battle for you guys yeah yeah
brand recognition sad as i am to say
that i mean the benefit for it coming
out on like something like hulu
substitutes direct to it here for you
got the channel and i'm looking forward
to that yeah because this looks pretty
excellent um in spite of whatever random
cheese there is i wish they
felt sure they would go full-on
commitment to just keeping them in their
native tongue i would love nothing more
than to have it be like full apocalypto
just like exactly speak the native
language and just subtitle it and please
go from there they'd really get those
box office or who subscriptions with
that yes they would everyone who joins
for
american productions with subtitles is
the most popular genre i mean there's
parts of this i feel like the revenant
meet prey yeah totally what's that
because of the bear what's that yeah is
that movie called the edge with the the
bear yeah any nature movies with bears
that's what this reminds me of that's
right that's all the bear moves
bear fight movies all right guys what
did you think about the prey trailer
leave your thoughts down below the
trailer talk to you guys soon